[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a
president honourable members thank you
for giving me
the opportunity to say a few words on
the eu recovery package
submitted by the commission today this
is still very fresh
and the delegations are studying it as
we meet
you will therefore understand that i am
not in a position to address the
substance of the proposals
there will be other occasions for that
at this stage
i would like to recall the delegation's
expectations and tell you how the
presidency intends to take the work
forward
first i will start with expectations
at the end of the april leaders agreed
to work towards establishing
a recovery fund and i quote which is
needed
and urgent their expectations is that
this fund shall be of a sufficient
magnitude
targeted toward the sectors and
geographical parts
of the europe most affected and be
dedicated to dealing with this
unprecedented crisis
the commission was therefore tasked to
analyze the exact needs
and urgently come up with the proposal
that is
commensurate with the challenge we are
facing
the commission was expected to clarify
the link with the mff
which according to the leaders will need
to be adjusted to the deal with the
current crisis
and its consequences as a response to
this tasking
the commission prepared a comprehensive
package
of the horizontal proposals which is
presented today
the political guidance was clear
delegations will
assess the package in this slide and
work on the details
starts down turning now to how the
presidency intends to organize the work
the key word is urgency last month
the leaders emphasized their commitment
to reaching an agreement
as soon as possible we all know that
time is running out
and we need to move ahead as fast as
possible
our economies require it our citizens
expect it
it is therefore the presidency's
responsibility to take work forward
on the commission's proposal without of
delay
in line with that the ministers of the
european affairs held a discussion
on a comprehensive economical and social
recovery of the eu
including an adjusted mff and recovery
instrument
at an informal video conference
yesterday furthermore
we put on topic on the agenda of coreper
for a first discussion
immediately after presentation of the
package already today
technical work will also be required to
understand the proposals
before leaders can have a meaningful
discussion to that end we will mobilize
the council
at all level both physical and with help
with
our with technology though out
we will be attentive to the parliament's
views
in in this spirit we reviewed carefully
the resolution you adopted at the last
plenary
on the new ff own resources
and recovery plan as mentioned on that
occasion continuous cooperation between
the council
and the european parliament will be an
essential part of the process
whether either at horizontal level or a
sectorial level
i take this occasion to remind you that
beyond the mff agreement
there are dozens of other negotiations
they concern programs
that turn eu support into actions on the
ground
there too time is of the essence we have
to make
as much progress as possible at
sectorial level
we need to make the most of the time
available now
we owe it to all the future
beneficiaries of these programs
including students small businesses
local authorities
and others now more than ever they will
need our support
to get their projects off the ground
this is too
will help the recovery of the our
economies
our regions and our cities and we look
forward to working with you
to meet these expectations thank you
very much for your attention
grazia grazie ministro edison president
destruction
unique
today we face our very own defining
moment started with a virus so
small your eyes couldn't see it has
become an economic crisis
so big that you simply cannot miss it
our unique model built over seventy
years
is being challenged like never before in
our lifetime
on our union's history the common
european goods we have built together
are being damaged things we take for
granted
are being questioned there's the single
market that needs to recover
there's the playing field that needs to
be made even again
there are four freedoms that need to be
fully restored
the crisis has huge externalities and
spillovers across
all countries and none of that
can be fixed by any single country
alone a bankrupt company in one a member
state
is a reliable supplier gone for business
in another
a struggling economy in one part of
europe
weakens a strong economy in another part
this is about all of us and it is way
bigger than any of us this is
europe's moment we see the economic
fiscal and social fall out across
all member states divergences
and disparities widen complex
questions of sovereignty and burden
sharing have to be balanced
and so in front of us once again
is that same binary choice
we either all go it alone
leaving countries regions and people
behind
and accepting a union of haves
and haves not have nuts or we walk that
road together
we take that leap forward we pave a
strong path for our people
and for the next generation and for me
the choice is simple i want us to take a
new
bold step together europe is in a unique
position to be able to invest
in a collective recovery and a common
future
in our union people business and
companies
depend and rely on each other
in our union cohesion convergence
and investment are good for all
and in our union we know that the
boldest
measures truly are the safest for the
future
and this is why the commission is today
proposing a new recovery instrument
called next generation eu
worth 750 billion euro
it will sit on top of our revamped
long-term eu budget of 1.1
trillion next generation eu together
with
the core mff sums up to 1.85
trillion euro in today's proposal
it goes alongside the three safety nets
of
540 billion euro
already agreed by parliament and council
and in some
this would bring our recovery effort to
a total
of 2.4 trillion euro
honorable members allow me to explain
how next generation eu will work
the money will be raised by temporarily
lifting
the own resources ceiling to allow the
commission to use its very strong credit
rating
to borrow money on the financial markets
this is an urgent and exceptional
necessity
for an urgent and exceptional crisis
next generation eu will invest in
repairing
our social fabric protect our single
market help
rebalancing balance sheets across europe
and while we are doing this we
need to press fast forward towards a
green
a digital and resilient future
because this is the future of europe's
next generation
this generation that is globally
connected and feels responsible for our
world
our planet with a clear vision
to promote human dignity and the rule of
law
determined to hold governments more
accountable
for fighting climate change and saving
our nature
driven by the idealism for europe
and the belief that our union must
strive for better
so beyond showing solidarity to overcome
the prices of today
i want to propose a new generational
pact
for tomorrow yes the effects of this
crisis
mean that we need to make investments on
an
unprecedented scale today
but we will do it in a way that europe's
next generation
will reap will harvest the benefits
tomorrow
investments that will not only preserve
the outstanding achievements of the last
70 years
but that will ensure that our union is
climate mutual
is digital is social and a strong global
player also in the future
and to make this happen next generation
eu will direct
its massive financial power to invest in
our common priorities through european
programs
and honorable members i'm always keen to
ensure that this house
has its full say on crucial decisions
of our union my proposal
to invest these funds via programs in
our european budget
achieves exactly that
next generation eu will restore and
rebuild our single market
that great generator of innovation
prosperity
and opportunity all member states need
to invest in technologies
that will spark the recovery through new
innovation
and clean industries next generation eu
strengthens the european green deal
and horizon europe and will invest in
key infrastructure
from 5g to housing renovation
at the same time we must ensure that the
transition
to climate neutral economy leaves nobody
behind
next generation eu will therefore
multiply
the funding for the just transition fund
and in the same vein no member
state should have to choose between
responding to the crisis
or investing in our people therefore
next generation eu
increases erasmus and youth employment
support
it makes sure that people get the skills
and the training
and the education they need to adapt to
this rapidly changing world
next generation eu will help those
perfectly healthy companies
that have made the right decisions and
investment over decades
but that find themselves at risk now
because competitors and other member
states
have better access to public or private
money
to get fresh capital it will
invest in key european industries and
technologies
to make crucial supply chains more
resilient
it will ensure europe remains cutting
edge
in key areas like artificial
intelligence precision farming
or green engineering and next generation
eu
will help make our health systems more
resilient
for future crisis this
investment will be a new or european
common good it will show the true
and tangible value of being part of the
union
and it will be owned by us all
in total the commission will raise 7 750
billion euro
for next generation eu of that total
500 billion will be distributed in
grants
and two hundred fifty billion in loans
passed on to member states
clashed and these are two synthetic
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
mr president madam president and
gentleman your colleagues
solidarity is back european solidarity
is back
the spirit of robert schumann is back
european flags burned a few weeks ago on
the streets in
italy for example millions of people
inside of the european union
are still concerned even afraid about
the future about the job about the
families
and europe is giving today a strong
answer you are not
alone be together will pick up the
challenge and give a good answer
with the fundament of solidarity we open
even
a new chapter for the european union
the colleagues some call it as an
hamilton moment
the current situation frankly speaking
as an epp politician i don't like it
because i don't want to see europe uh
argued europe based
on making debts on on borrowing money
that is not my dream about
europe but having the situation in mind
the economic crisis in mind the middle
of the biggest economic crisis since the
second world war
we see no alternative has to invest now
to give
our economy a new boost and the key
question for us is not first of all
how massive massive the investment will
be how much money do we spend
that is not the first question for us
the first question is what
is it for and one of our principles is
and that is guaranteed now
with the proposal we guarantee that we
are not having fresh money for the old
problems of the continent
we have to guarantee that we use fresh
money for the new ideas for the fresh
future for this continent another
element which is crucial was crucial for
us in the debates since the preparatory
process was
the democratic procedures and i thank
the commission president for the clear
statement now we have to go to the
council and also clarify with the
council
that the principle that no money can be
spent in european level
without the approval of the european
parliament is also guaranteed
from the council side the proposal is
now on the table and
dear colleagues we have still to argue
to convince
27 member states parliaments are needed
to support this
general idea and it's funny to see that
in my camp in the epp we have one
government we have two socialist
government we have
one liberal government in netherlands
and even the greens are part of the
problem this time because in
austria they are governing so it's
really good to see that all of us
we have the same challenge now to
convince the others to support
the general idea that is still in front
of us and to the frugal four
let me be clear with three main
arguments first of all
our companies or your companies cannot
be successful
without a successful single market so
it's in your interest
to make the whole european union
successful the second argument is
we see a redistribution of the global
economic power going on
and i don't want to see the china
recipient winner in europe is a big
loser
and the third argument is in 2008 910 we
had already
faced already the phenomena of a lost
generation
and europe cannot accept another lost
generation in
in this time in this crisis that's why i
think we have good arguments for
convincing some
for us solidarity goes always hand in
hand with
responsibility that is always two sides
of the same coin for us as epp
and having this in mind i tell you that
when we go to the markets now borrow
money we have to be clear to kevin full
and strong and serious idea honest idea
how to pay it back and to say that in
the next mff
having the debates in march in mind when
the
council tried already to find a common
understanding about
the the mff of today i
don't believe that this will be so easy
that's why
as epp let's be honest let's be clear
and that means we need own resources for
paying back the debt we have now
installed the big winner of the crisis
of the digital giants
and that's why i think it's fair to ask
the digital
giants to pay part of the debt we are
creating now
and another part of this solidarity
responsibility
is for us also the national perspective
you can call it semester
you can call it the need of internal
reforms
i think it is simply fair if you ask
your neighbor to help you to practice
solidarity
it's simply fair to do your homework to
be better prepared for the future
and in a globalized world we need still
reforms
there are thousands of other principles
which are important rule of law
a key issue epp supports this the grants
loan debate
i think we have now good compromise on
the table the health program is upgraded
a big signal important signal in today's
corona time
and the mff there we will still have
further discussions
than it is about agriculture and
cohesion so
the plan goes in a good direction it's
an important moment for the future of
the european union
and the epp will generally support the
ideas from the commission thank you so
[Applause]
much
presenting
[Applause]
thank you president dear colleagues this
health and economic crisis we face
is a game changer unprecedented
in the history of european union the
magnitude of this crisis and its
extraordinary challenges
require a sizable and rapid response
there is no alternative either we find a
solution to invest massively in our
economy
or we accept that will be hit even
harder
let me be clear this is a package for
all member states and all members that
need this package
irrespective of how bad they were
affected
by the health of economic crisis because
the internal market
is at stake if the internal market fails
every citizen and businesses in the
european union will suffer
the solution by president vanderlian for
the commission to borrow money
from the market it's a remarkable one we
have to recognize
our opinion may differ in some details
but i really welcome the approach
a european solution for your european
problem
it also avoid the major difficulty we
had during this last crisis
creating more debts for some member
states
when in fact they need money to inject
immediately in
their economies decisions that we take
now will define europeans road for the
next 20 30 years
because we invest massively now not only
to recover but
to relaunch and to modernize our economy
so we are creating depth for the
generations to come and that is why
mff and recovery package should focus on
the future
not stay fixed and on ideas from the
past
first we need to restore economic
perspectives
we need to safeguard and create new jobs
we need to focus on investment with real
economic
year and european added value the green
deal and digital agenda should be
the building blocks of a resilient and
sovereign european
economy second solidarity is key
the fight against territorial divides
and inequalities across europe
will be the breeding ground for our
union or the seeds of our future
division so that's why we
must stand united third the european
union is not
a cash machine it's a common project
where solidarity comes with values and
the shared vision
for our future and that's why a re
renew europe group will only support mff
where rule of law and respect of
european values
are a condition to receiving european
funds
not to penalize people but the
politicians who do not play
by the rules fourth certainly there are
many lessons to be learned from this
crisis
reasons to reform and improve areas
where the european union needs to be
more present
and that is why the conference on the
future of europe
our common future should get underway
the road to recovery will be long and
hard the decision
we take these days will affect the
future
of millions of people the future of
internal market
and the future of our european union and
that is why
european union must stay united and
fight as one
thank you
[Applause]
is
keller parola
thank you very much we have indeed a
very deep crisis in europe and we need
to
react to that and i think it's a big
moment of response responsibility of
thinking together that we're joining
hands and we're thinking of
how to get together out of this crisis
in this parliament with the broad
majority has shown a way forward
with a substantial recovery fund a
strong mff a strong budget
and a green deal that helps the economy
while addressing the climate crisis
and the biodiversity crisis which have
gone nowhere
and i'm very glad to say that greens all
over europe are actually supporting that
so
i'm a bit i'm afraid mr baber dear
manfred that it's a bit cheap to hide
behind the grains
when we actually have a strong support
also public support from the austrian
grains who are supporting our position
and the position of this parliament
maybe it's rather your best friend in
vienna
who is causing the problem but i'm glad
to see that you're also ready
uh and willing to convince him and try
to convince him and i'm glad we can join
forces there
and try indeed our common job to
convince
governments all over parties all over
because that is
what we need to do now because i do
believe that the commission proposal is
a very
big step forward and we welcome the
focus
that you've put on grants to make sure
that no member state is left behind in
this crisis
the overall volume might not prove
sufficient in time but in any case
what we need to make sure is that we
don't lessen the ambitions
on the mff because we also need to think
further ahead
you have mentioned colleagues have
mentioned conditions attached
to the fund and i would urge us all to
not
repeat the big mistakes of the past and
forced countries into austerity and
blind market ideological ideologies
that have never worked and will not work
instead we need to make sure that the
money is well invested
into projects that will help in the long
term that create jobs
and that save the one planet that we
have and to be meaningful in the long
term
both the recovery fund and the mff need
to incentivize the social ecological
transformation of our economy
and promote gender equality big problem
we've seen in this crisis
and they also need to follow follow our
minimum common rules
such as the rule of law and democracy
some governments think that they can do
it all alone but i think
they should think again they have all
benefited as much as and even more than
other member states from the single
market
from freedom of movement and some
unfortunately also from a bit
too lacks tax rules dear colleagues
europe
needs a strong step ahead it needs
courageous action
like that of schumann 70 years ago and
this parliament
has shown it's ready to do its part i
hope the member states will follow
thank you
[Applause]
president
[Applause]
president
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much mr president
president fonder line welcome to the
european parliament and thank you for
your proposal
dear colleagues today is an important
day because the citizens of europe
expect help and support from the
european union and today we can tell
them
help is coming we are creating a package
the european union
is delivering this is a new instrument
the support which it grants
will be concrete it will make a
difference for people
for companies for regions and for
countries
what are the next steps today is only
the beginning we need to create the best
recovery package possible
and for this the european parliament
needs to be fully involved
in this recovery package the colleagues
here in the room they are coming from
all regions of europe
they are in direct and in permanent
contact with the citizens they know
exactly
what the needs on the ground are what
hospitals need what companies need
what people need and this is why we say
the european parliament has to be
fully involved in how the money of the
recovery package is being spent
but also in how the money of the
recovery package is being paid back
the involvement of the european
parliament will ensure that the recovery
package
is the best recovery package that we can
jointly and together create
this recovery package will have an
impact upon the future of the citizens
and this is why this house which
represents the citizens of the european
union
needs to be involved in all aspects and
dear colleagues we also need to see the
whole picture president from the line
was speaking about the the
budget as a whole we need to create a
recovery package which supports
uh the people and the economy um to come
out of the corona crisis but we should
also not forget
about the old priorities of the eu
budget we should not forget
about farmers about students
we should not forget our new priorities
the green deal the security of citizens
digitalization
and we should have enough reserves to
respond to still
unpredictable crisis that will for sure
occur in the next seven years
these are the principles of our work we
are ready to work with the european
commission on this basis
and we expect the commission to work
with the parliament on this basis thank
you very much
[Applause]
from
optimization
sure
[Applause]
thank you mr chairman and first of all i
would like to thank the commission for
its proposal
because this is creating a room for an
investment plan an investment plan that
europe badly needs
and should also come from europe not
only from the member states
because we do know if we leave it to the
member states we will get an unbalanced
imbalance that is bigger and bigger in
this internal market what we see already
half of the state aid is coming from
germany at the moment
just showing the imbalance and that is
why we need a european investment
program
and that is why this is so important i
would like to thank you for that
it's really also being thanked by all
the different political greens
and we do hope that from the other
political families including my
government in the netherlands
that they are seeing how badly needed
such
a new modern investment program is
needed but this for commission also
means that we need to be sure
that the investments are going to the
green deal and digitalization
and that is there in words but really it
now boils down also to
how to put it into action and there i
have one question to the commission
we are talking about 750 billion now but
in state eight we are talking about more
than two thousand billion
and there still the support is
unconditioned
european commission madame vesta make
the rules to also condition the state
aid
because conditions needs here but also
for the national investment and then we
can prosper
and get to the new economy that europe
so badly needs thank you very much
[Music]
foreign
thank you very much mr president um
regardless of substance it is quite
appalling
that the european union once again in
such a critical time
hammers out a deal behind closed doors
everyone that criticizes the european
union for a lack of transparency
is quite right and i think if the eu
wants to appear democratic
it better starts acting like it i can
only hope
that unlike the last uh merkel
macron deal back in june 2018 about the
fiscal union
this deal will fare much better that one
vanished into thin air and we haven't
heard anything of it
since its announcement and declaration
i can only hope uh that this
uh package will deliver and
however i have certain concerns i am
concerned
that this 500 billion fund is not
acting like a euro bond it is not going
to transfer
debt from member states to the level of
the european union and it is only going
to add
to the unbearable debt level of certain
member states which will bring about
austerity in the upcoming years will be
which will be crushing
for these economies also i can only hope
and see
that i will see guarantees in this
recovery package
that the funds don't go to the big
multinational companies and corporations
but to smes small and medium-sized
companies which are the backbone
of the european economy thank you
my main concern is the fact that we're
now entering into debt
that is unavoidable in this crisis but
it's unclear how and when it is going to
be repaid
and my concern is that if we don't get
on resources because if one member state
opposes we won't get them
um that then in the end we will have to
use our european budget to actually
repay this debt
having less money at our disposal to do
actually actual politics and policies
and therefore i would like to see a real
commitment from council
that we get own resources in time or
that we start
a repayment plan within this mff already
we need clarity uh for this program to
work
and then let me say one thing to madame
garcia perez
i've just said in dutch my mother tongue
because i think it's important
that we need to shoulder this proposal
all together that we're all in the same
boat and that we need to work together
but if you propose making this a matter
of 23
against four we won't succeed you will
push those four countries in the arms of
the extreme right
if you say let's do this without
unanimity
count on the pro-european forces in
those countries among which i
include myself to get this done but we
will have to do it together
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you president colleen
um
um
foreign
um
[Music]
[Applause]
president
is
[Music]
[Music]
thank
[Applause]
europe is defined as a political project
by the answer
it gives to its crisis many citizens
have bad memories about how we manage
the last financial crisis
they were made guilty of the excesses of
their governments
and the incompetence in planning
economic
and industrial change we cannot allow
this to happen again
we must take this opportunity for europe
through next generation eu
to work more directly with citizens and
enterprises
to really overcome national frontiers to
empower a network of
regions and metropolitan areas that can
be effective
quick to react and close to the people
we must choose and europe as an
enormous manager of some obsolete states
unable to deal with the future or and
europe as a cooperative of citizens
equal in rights and freedoms that brings
back to the people returns in terms of
social
cultural and democratic progress next
generation you is a first step
go ahead without hesitation
is
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you madam chair yes in the midst
of this unprecedented health crisis no
one is left
untouched people are falling ill
losing loved ones seeing their
businesses suffer
and losing their jobs it's a cause for
people to reflect
to question what is really important and
what should our priorities be
in the same way we should re-evaluate
the european budget facing this crisis
and knowing we still have other
challenges to address
people look for to us for a unified
response
to advance money wisely be accountable
and not to pass the burden to the new
future generations to achieve this
we need to prioritize what is important
we should ask ourselves how can we
refocus
and reform our economies to come out of
this crisis stronger
but together just like our citizens
trying to adapt in this crisis
we need to adapt so we can recover and
build
a renewed resilience thank you very much
thank you
thank you for president information
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
b
[Music]
thank you very much madam president
honorable members of the european
parliament
my dear colleagues from the european
commission at first i really would like
to thank you for what i felt
was very strong overwhelming support in
most of the intervention for the
ambitious
proposal the commission has tabled today
and i really would like to thank you for
the inspirations
with that many occasions withdrew from
this house
from your resolutions from your debates
we had
with you when we've been looking for
the ways how to best respond to your
calls
for demonstrating bigger solidarity for
using this crisis
as opportunity to modernize european
economy
and for consolidate the position of
europe as a global actor and global
player
we proposed the proposals which was
never
done before it's really sun's precedent
because
what we wanted to do was to adapt the
initial
multi-annual financial perspective
proposal to the current needs
and because we fully realize that the
economic crisis
is so sharp and so deep we knew that we
need
to come up with a new instrument which
we named
next generation eu all together
we are talking about 1.1 trillion of the
proposal
for mff an additional 750 billion
of euros for the next generation
instrument which would be divided
between grants and loans as you
suggested in your resolution i very much
appreciate
that mr webber madame garcia perez mr
cholos
supported this approach and i would like
to reassure you
that we know that the success
of these proposals would be judged by
the
results if we invest the money
in the right areas and we definitely
want to do that we fully realize that if
we want to modernize european economy we
have to invest in green sustainable
technologies
we have to be much more digital than we
are right now
and we have to learn our lessons for
improving the resilience
of the european economy because we
learned how difficult it is to be
dependent on some global value chains or
single supplier of such sensitive health
materials
as we have seen over the last
few months so what we put on the table
is the proposal have to not only
overcome the crisis
but how to modernize it how to respect
the important
social aspects of our policy
and how to make europe really ready for
the post-covet
21st century world a lot of questions
and some of them presented with a great
vigor
being linked
to the depths and also to their own
resources mr moyten madame aubry
mr van overweld here again i would like
to tell you that we did
our homework we studied the issue very
carefully
and we are coming with the different
options for the
own resources which you want to of
course explore with you
and with the member states we want
to use the new ets revenues visually
coming
eventually from the aviation and
maritime sector
to use them for financing parts of the
mff in the future we are considering
so-called single
market uh tax especially
from those companies which are
benefiting from the fact that silver
market is so big
and functions that well we will be
following
carefully how other countries and powers
on this planet are respecting the
paris goals and if they're really
reducing the carbon footprint
of the products and of the economy and
we would be ready to proceed
if necessary with the carbon adjustment
tax which again could be the renew
revenue
of the european budget and we are of
course not
forgetting about the possibility of the
digital taxations
where of course we want to have a global
agreement preferably within oecd or g20
but if that
would not if this would not work we are
ready to consider
to go alone and uh madame sidlow
and mr asman have been highlighting the
importance of the
tax evasion and unfair tax practices
this is of course one of the priorities
upon which we are going to focus and for
us the
proper executions of the european budget
and proper tax collection
is of course one of the key priorities
to be quite honest i didn't quite get
the the comment
of the honorable member john joshi who
was criticizing us for
lack of transparency at 12 o'clock we
in the college adopted these very
important proposals
and one o'clock the whole college was
here the european parliament
was the first audience where we
presented
our proposals where our president went
to a great detail
what you want to do how we want to
accomplish it
and therefore i think that that
tradition where we fully respect
the democratic scrutiny of the european
parliament would be of course maintained
in the future and we will be debating
with you all of the legislative
proposals which are very complex and
where we need the close
uh cooperation and very close uh
consultation
there have been several questions linked
with the state aid i have to say that uh
my colleague executive vice president
madam westagger is known for her vigor
in reviewing and assessing every single
stay-date
application and we also have to
agree that these last three months been
totally exceptional at first we had to
fight for the lives of our citizens
then for the livelihoods and for the
jobs and this
is what we've been with your help doing
uh since the beginning
of this year if you allow me madame
uh president to conclude with a plea
with a request because i think that
we are at a truly historic
european moment where we need all of us
to show
clear political leadership
we would very much appreciate the strong
support
of the european parliament as mr
gonzalez
has highlighted but we also need your
help
to convince your compatriots back home
therefore i'm also addressing